dans c'est mon choix sur chérie 25 on a
fait la connaissance de maria christina
maria cristina c'est une quadragénaire
qui entretient une relation très
particulière avec claire clair qu'il ya
vingt ans je vous en dis pas plus
regardés et on s'en parle juste après je
pense que le débat va être houleux maria
cristina oui cette jeune fille c'est
votre fille non mon ex belle fille en
fait si je comprends bien clair vous
étiez la petite copine de sa fille ça
depuis deux ans comment vous avez
annoncé votre copie c'est pas moi qui
doit annoncer en fait c'est moi je dis
voilà je suis très amoureuse de claire
et là en fait mais elle a poussé des
cris bas alors voilà déchiré sa robe
elle a ajouté son portable c'était
horrible elle en a plus voulu à moi qu'à
clair le puits sera là mais c'est normal
je comprends que c'est une sensation que
je crois qu'il ya très peu de gens qui
l'ont connu ce à un coût tout mais
vraiment créer un jardin ou de foudre
c'est en fait ça vole pas de mettre en
danger sa fille de la rend triste pour
un coup de foudre comme ça oui
alors moi je vous avoue que je suis un
coach et pour cette jeune fille qui à
double trahison c'est terrible c'est à
dire votre amoureuse au vôtre
pour eux qui part avec votre père ou
votre mais enfin c'est un truc de dingue
caroline j'ai l'impression non vous
n'êtes pas si choqué que ça bien sûr la
démagogie à paris nommé dont l'estrie
populaire voudrait qu'on dise ah là là
mon dieu c'est horrible
comment ça peut arriver non mais
attendez je vous rappelle un truc
l'amour n'a pas de loi d'accord non mais
bien aux lignes en jeu rien on fait ce
qu'on peut
et amour il soit de loin je veux bien
caroline mais demain demain votre fille
qui est encore tout petit mais imagine
imaginons elle revient avec un petit
fiancée oui que vous trouvez bien à
votre goût et voulu piquer le fiancé
avec chipie confiance et ses passages
histoire qui puisse arriver à
marie-christine à la pauvre elle ou sa
forte elle un truc de fou des balades
deux jours de travaux les accompagne sa
fille et elle a un coup de foudre
donc après il faut juste assumer le fait
que l on un coup de foudre qui est
totalement bilingue et ralik j allais
dès maintenant de votre fille parce que
vous avez un coup de foudre pour son
fiancé martel et yale et vous ça voulait
aussi dire que l'histoire entre les deux
petites la presse comme la marque assure
que s'il en est bien sûr que c'est que
je loue est ça aussi encore une fois je
le souhaite à personne je dis juste que
je pense que le coup de foudre
c'est à dire le truc qui ne se contrôle
pas qui mais qui arrive comme ça qui te
tombe dessus et c'est pour ça qu'on dit
aussi de tomber amoureux il n'ya pas à
ce moment là deux mois il en existe
normale et non en fait mais on peut très
bien tomber amoureux de 2,2 de
l'amoureux sa soeur bien ça peut arriver
maintenant
le truc c'est ne pas y aller parce que
ça c'est profondément morale mais le
fait d'avoir un coup de foudre
ces magasins de morale je ne sais pas ce
que j'imagine cette jeune fille qui voit
sa mère partir avec sa fiancée
c'est une sorte de double trahison là
pour le coup on peut plus se fier ni à
sa mère ni à son amour pour ajouter
encore des gens reconnaissent et une
fille bien passé pour relire je
reconnais je reconnais que banks damien
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors moi
je n'ai pas vrai je pas du tout d'accord
avec toi moi j'ai pas vraiment le sens
du partage admettons demain je suis
invité à un dîner je ramène une dinde
bien grasset puissante je n'ai pas envie
qu'on tape dedans je suis désolé mais si
c'est pour aller voir mais attends mais
oui mais
notre avis c'est tout d'abord culinaire
je ne compare pas mon épouse à une bande
d'abord c'est vrai que je n'ai pas
j'aime pas quand on picore dans mon
assiette c'est tout après toi tu as des
moeurs un peu particulière parce que je
suis désolé à partir du moment où c'est
la famille bizarre parce que j'ai dit
c'est parfois non mais ça veut dire que
c'est ben oui mais si c'est si doux si
votre papa par exemple tombé amoureux de
votre votre femme
bah je m'exile dans une tente en
mongolie je sais pas mais je coupe les
ponts avec tout le monde quoi j'aurais
voulu vous voudriez il aurait franchi
oui après oui c'est rédhibitoire
d'accord de djibo il faut souligner
quelque chose que personne n'a relevé
c'est le dilemme qui peut y avoir ça
dépend d'eux parce qu'il ya deux jours
en fait ça dépend mais oui si c'est
votre père assis mon père qui drague ma
fiancée
oui là il ya problème et a bagarré
octogone y aller si c'est elle qui va
vers lui comme ça c'est peut-être un peu
passé avec marie christine a hélas on
peut se dire que finalement votre père
et et étant un homme est faible ces
normes et que nous sommes tout à fait
différent entre la faute alors si c'est
votre perle c'est ta faute et si c'est
elle qui drague ce sera de sa faute à
elle est donc c'est moins grave
oui oui en effet parce que les autorités
vous êtes on est tout à fait faible on
est tout à fait faible encore comme et
on se fait avoir on se fait avoir donc
je peux le comprendre je ne tolère pas
mais je peux le comprendre et faire que
si on connaît la nuance bah écoutez
c'est subtil mais les minimes ont
terminé je suis effaré j'en peux plus de
déglingo d'accord imaginez le truc ça
qu'elle va faire nano nanette avec
quelqu'un qui a fait nan nan est avec sa
fille c'est juste pas possible
et moi si ça devait m'arriver notre
transposons parce que votre nom par
exemple elle irait avec votre témoin si
noémie part avec ma mère ouais elle part
mais loin mais genre en australie parce
qu'il vaut mieux pas lui faire croiser
et ma mère et l'eau et me savais d'aller
à vous couper les ponts avec toi m'ont
aidé à prévenir j'ai décidé que ma mère
est nominé ne verrait plus nous sortir
avec son ex gendre ou son ex brute est
ce que vous êtes choqués ou pas choquer
fenêtre sharks à 68% vous n'êtes quand
même 11 % pas être choqué il ya des gens
qui sont plutôt du côté de carole assez
libre en dix ans après tout l'amour n'a
pas de limites
mais voler je ne dirais pas ça de nos
téléspectateurs jamais mais jamais des
illégaux ce scénario ya pas mal d'hommes
peut-être pas mal d'hommes peut-être est
faible mais bon certains séduisent leur
vos parents d'autres préfèrent leur
faire peur
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]